لم تخفف الفوضى غير المسبوقة في موسكو بعد
القتال المرير لأوكرانيا في
الخنادق من القتال المتقارب حول باكاموت بعد
أسبوعين من استمرار
عمليات الهجوم المضاد المفتوحة التي تم تصويرها
خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع في الوقت الذي تدحرجت فيه قوات فاجنر
نحو موسكو
هنا ، فالأبيض والأحمر والأزرق من الروس
في حالة من الفوضى والاستسلام ، سيتبع ذلك الأمل
أكثر حيث تنتشر الكلمات عن
التمرد الفاشل وتعثر الروح المعنوية والانضباط ،
كانت قريبة من هنا أعلنت أوكرانيا يوم
الاثنين التقدم على الخطوط الأمامية مع وجود
مساحة للأمل في مكان آخر
في الجنوب على جبهة دونيتسك أخرى
بالقرب من المتنازع عليها بشدة  marinka
يبدو أن بعض المقاتلين الشيشان الموالين للكرملين قد تم
سحبهم إلى موسكو للدفاع عنها
في عطلة نهاية الأسبوع هنا ، وهم
يتمايلون على طول طريق سريع واضح بالقرب من
العاصمة
باشموت وفرص مارينكا
لأوكرانيا في الشرق ولكن أيضًا
غربًا بالقرب من هيرسون جسر أنطونيفسكي
اشتباكات عنيفة
استولت عليها هذه الطائرة الروسية بدون طيار حيث
ادعت القوات الأوكرانية عبورها
إلى الضفة الشرقية التي تسيطر عليها روسيا
وفتحت جبهة أخرى ربما
يكون من السابق لأوانه معرفة ما إذا كانت
روسيا تنهار وما إذا كان
تقدم أوكرانيا لا يزال تدريجيًا
هذا المشهد المألوف عندما
أعلن المقاتلون أنهم استولوا على
قرية صغيرة أخرى في
حبوب منع الحمل في الجنوب يوم الاثنين ،
ولم يحدث أي تغيير في البحر الاستراتيجي
والانهيار الروسي في
عطلة نهاية الأسبوع التي ستزور زيلينسكي
القوات في الشرق يوم الإثنين ، كما
يأمل أن يتبعه
يواجه خيارات قلقة حتى مع كل شيء.  إن
قبح الكرملين الحميم قد
كشف النقاب عن هذه
الخطوة الآن أو الانتظار لمزيد من الانهيار في موسكو ،
يجب أن يكون على يقين من عدم ارتكاب
أخطاء من جانبه أو مقاطعة
سيلهم
في موسكو.
بالنسبة إلى Goshen ، سيكون الآن بالطبع
تذكيرًا دائمًا بإخفاقات بوتين
أثناء وجوده في أي وقت مضى ويخرج
مقاطع الفيديو هذه
جيدًا أعتقد أن ما رأيناه في rastoff
أولاً وقبل كل شيء أظهر أن لديه
قاعدة خاصة به وأن الكثير من الناس
يشاهدون  هو وفاجنر كنوع من
الأبطال الشعبيين بسبب ما فعلوه في ساحة
المعركة في أوكرانيا ، وثانيًا
أعتقد أنه من بعض النواحي المنحرفة كما
يبدو أن بوتين كان يُظهر هذا النوع من
الشهامة الشبيهة بالقيصر وأعتقد أن هذا هو
السبب في أنك لم تفعل ذلك.  لا أراه يخطب حتى
اليوم ، أنا آسف ، ثم حتى أمس ، آه
لماذا رأيته نوعًا ما لا يحاول عدم جعل
يديه متسخين ويتصرف بطريقة
إزالة للسماح للآخرين بالتعامل مع هذا ،
إنها طريقة لإظهار أنه فوق
هذا ، إنه أكبر  من هذا ، وإذا كان هذا
الرجل يريد أن يعيش في المنفى ، فسوف
يمنحه هذا النوع من
الطلب الخيري ، وأعتقد أنه نوع من المسرح أيضًا ،
ما رأيك في أن يفعل الشعب الروسي
من كل هذا وبالطبع كم
يجب أن نقرأ  في
الحشود المبتهجة والداعمة المحيطة
بالتقدم في بداية مسيرته إلى
موسكو ، وهذا يمثل
كيف يشعر الكثير من الروس تجاهه
جيدًا بشكل خاص ، حيث جاء تورينج في نهاية
شهر مارس عندما كان ينسحب من
رستوف ، فمن الصعب أن  أخبر ما
يعتقده الناس الروس أنه كان من
الممكن أن يهتف الناس جزئيًا له مرة أخرى
لأن هذه الفكرة التي تعلم أنهم
يقاتلون من أجل الوطن الأم
يمكن أن يهتفوا له لأنه
بديل لبوتين وهو
يجلب أي نوع  من التغيير لا تعرفون
عدم التفكير حقًا في نوع
التغيير الذي قد يحدث إذا كان شخص ما
مثل wojin الكبير وهو
قومي متشدد وفاشي نوعًا ما
يتولى زمام الأمور ويعتمد
ذلك أيضًا على مكان
وجودك في البلد.  إعادة الحديث عن ذلك ، ربما في
الجنوب أقرب إلى الحرب ، يشعر الناس
بمزيد من أممم ،
ولا أعرف أكثر بالقرب منه في
أماكن مثل الكابيتول ، كان الناس
خائفين منه بشكل واضح ،
ويميل الناس في العاصمة إلى أن
يعيش الكثير منهم حياتهم  مرتبطًا
ببوتين والنظام الذي أنشأه لهذا
السبب لم تر أيًا منهم ينضم إلى أه
على الأقل في
انقلاب علني ، فقد جلسوا جميعًا
وانتظروا ليروا من سيفوز في النهاية
وأعتقد أنه كان هناك شعور حقيقي
بالارتياح عندما
تراجعت  استدار لأنهم
يفهمون أن التغيير قد يكون جيدًا ولكن
ربما لا يكون هذا النوع من التغيير وهم
أفضل من الجلوس جيدًا وركوب هذا
الخارج
جوليا يافي ، شكرًا جزيلاً على انضمامك
إلينا ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك.
أكبر اختبار حتى الآن لاقتباسهما
وصف الرئيس الصيني ، شي جين بينغ ،
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بأنه أفضل
صديق له وأكثرهم حميمية ، حيث
تعهد الزعيمان بإنشاء نظام عالمي جديد
معًا ناهيك عن أنهما يشتركان في
خصم أيديولوجي مشترك.
يرى بعض المحللين الأمريكيين أن الأحداث التي وقعت في نهاية هذا
الأسبوع في روسيا تضعف
قوة بوتين تاركة جيران روسيا في
الجنوب وأكبر حليف للصين يبحرون
في رحلة غير معلنة ووترز في
زيارة لم يعلن عنها سابقًا
سافر نائب وزير الخارجية الروسي على الفور إلى
بكين للقاء مسؤولين صينيين
في نهاية الأسبوع.  بما في ذلك مع
وزير الخارجية جين غونغ ،
يرى البعض أن هذا التدافع
لطمأنة الصين بأن روسيا مستقرة وأن
الأمور هناك كانت تحت السيطرة من
جانبها ، رددت وسائل الإعلام الحكومية الصينية
تلك الرواية حتى في سي إن إن في معظم
وسائل الإعلام الغربية التي بثت قافلة باغوزية
تتقدم في روسيا الصينية.  أظهر التلفزيون الحكومي
جوًا هادئًا سلميًا حول
الكرملين بشكل مثير للاهتمام ، على الرغم من أن
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الصينية التي تخضع لرقابة مشددة
أظهرت أن بعض المستخدمين يعربون عن قلقهم
بشأن ما قد يحدث في روسيا وكيف
يمكن أن يؤثر ذلك على الصين يوم
الأحد.
الشؤون الداخلية
والتعهد بدعمها لروسيا وحماية
الاستقرار الوطني أدى
دعم الصين الدبلوماسي والاقتصادي
لروسيا منذ غزو بوتين لأوكرانيا
بالطبع إلى توتر العلاقات مع
الغرب ، لكن المسؤولين الصينيين حاولوا أيضًا
تصوير أنفسهم على أنهم
حزب محايد وصانع سلام محتمل لإنهائه.
الصراع في أوكرانيا التهديد
بعدم الاستقرار في روسيا على الرغم من أن نهاية
الأسبوع الماضي قد تثير التسامح مع
جهود الصين لحل الحرب الروسية في
أوكرانيا
ديفيد كلفر سي إن إن لوس أنجلوس